foreign
back to where you were
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning it is cold in Tokyo luckily
we're going somewhere way hotter
let's go
it's all happening we're not sitting
next to each other we checked our fly
our seats take us too late but it's a
three hour flight
we're heading to regular car
and this mask will never stay on my face
last time we came to Okinawa I couldn't
rent the car because I forgot my
International license now it takes time
we're driving myself favorite car that's
Hustler
[Music]
we made it it's raining a little bit but
I think we should be okay so we're gonna
check out the local areas a little bit
see what's up I'm ready to buying let's
go
[Music]
we're a little unlucky with the weather
but hey what can you do it's beautiful
stuff it's really warm too so now we're
going to the local Village
and hopefully I have some delicious food
check out some shops but we have about
five kilometer bike ride to get there
you seen something
whoa you're right damn it looks so blue
even in a rainy day
damn oh what are we having Okinawa I
don't recognize a lot of these they have
melon cream soda I Gotta Have It hell
yeah
oh it's so good
I love melon
and I love cream
and I love soda
[Music]
I feel so odd that it's January
and we're in Japan
I don't know it's very disorienting it
hasn't processed that we're here yet so
I'm just kind of like where are we are
we in Spain the Canary Islands no oh I
took off without Marjan
look at that
[Music]
oh
brain picked off of it
God damn it oh my God it's hard to find
in the rain we got a couple more
kilometers to go we can do this
[Music]
this shrimp is so good
yeah show me uh
even with the spoon
we got some souvenir shops
we just had some amazing food I feel so
good right now
we're just rolling around there's a ton
of cool souvenir shop so we're just
looking for gifts for people if you
don't return with game without umiage
like gifts in Japan you're in big
trouble so
[Music]
he's holding out a beer
do you guys hear this
whoa
oh they are so loud that's gotta be
frogs I think holy moly
oh my oh they're in the sewer
but they stopped as soon as I came
I want to see one
come on Froggies don't be scared we were
supposed to go stargazing tonight but
because of the
the rain we have to cancel which is a
shame but it was still a really nice
first day tomorrow we have a ton of
stuff we're going to a different Island
so we're taking a boat
mice is worried that I'm gonna be
seasick because I told her I've been
seasick but I'm gonna be totally fine
and then we're gonna ride a cow
[Music]
I was gifted by our bike rental Awan
NAMI awamuri it's a local Okinawan
very nice gift thank you I will try it I
don't really drink anymore but I feel
like I should try it it smells like
really strong socket
yeah it's nice me and Mario's Gonna Love
trash TV if we're watching the the
Traders British in it oh God that
alcohol basically a Mangus
and everyone cries over the tiniest
thing it's hilarious
[Music]
good morning we're supposed to go on a
boat ride but it looks like the weather
is yet again against this we might have
some change of plans if they're still
gonna go or not but we'll see now we're
just gonna have breakfast my hair is
already ruined God damn you win
[Music]
is so cute
we found a tree
he's hanging in there we arrived at a
viewing point they have some crazy
looking rocks here also a crazy looking
bathroom
love a good bathroom where do you mind
see you go I don't know
I'll find her
oh she's gonna creep me out
you look so tiny
what is this
yeah
oh okay it's a viewing point
whoa you can see the whole island almost
damn that's the best point of view
[Music]
oh this is scary you can go even higher
wow
that's so cool
you're in the center of Okinawa now
[Music]
I spy an Italian pizza pie
thank you
oh my God I'm actually
oh God
we're going to the lighthouse
I thought it was windy before
that was wrong he told me
it's incredibly strong winds up there
they're stumbling that's so funny
talk to me in Japanese
but he said be careful whoa
what of you
[Music]
foreign
eat what it does to my hair but it's
really fun that was very cool
[Music]
a heap of rice
it's so cute you know what they say when
you're in Okinawa you get fish and chips
it's really good
[Music]
two hours
all right guys
open up
uh
[Music]
we're checking out the mall since the
weather is quite bad today I'm gonna do
some glass blowing I think I'll be quite
the talent
[Music]
that's crazy
thank you
foreign
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
that was surprisingly fun actually did I
do a good job did it look like I know
what I'm saying they're gonna send it
home to us we're heading back to the
hotel now to chill you may continue
cutting my hand out thank you thank you
now let's see what it looks like
I hate going to the hairdresser someone
said that's been cutting my hair since
coven it's also it takes a lot of time
when I say it's fast she's slow now
because I'm pressuring her
what
you do
I love it thank you
good job how much are you fix it look at
my titties though
the next skin
10 out of 10.
[Music]
good morning today is our last day in
ishigaki we are finishing off strong
with a Mensa experience which is a
Okinawan type of textile well I haven't
had so much talent as glass blowing we
will see
foreign
[Music]
thank you oh my God you made so much
more progress than me you're almost done
you're doing good
[Music]
so these are very old type right Louis
Vuitton
they have some explaining to there they
were so nice
so this is the greatest place ever it's
really pretty actually I didn't think I
would appreciate textile but it's kind
of cool to see how they make it as well
we found egg in Momo we got some sun now
it looks so nice just as we're about to
leave we're gonna have some lunch and
then head to the airport
[Music]
foreign
looks great it's always possible to find
veggie stuff in Japan you just gotta
know where to like
[Music]
this is our hotel is super quirky check
it out
[Music]
[Applause]
look at this
embarrassing event this big I know it's
two beds but still bam like
that's so cute
[Music]
laughs
I think I'm quiet in that up officer
I hate Mass
minus I think this is Peak comedy
apparently I don't do masks
playing rafts
or trying to rap you're in yeah we're
stuck on this island because
good morning
I feel like I'm in Gothenburg looking
out here
I don't know why it's tripping me out I
think this hotel is kind of Scandinavian
Interiors here we got a full pack
scheduled today nothing's canceled
weather looks great
Japan UK Sweden I never live without my
G fuel
this is really really beautiful they
always have mackerel for breakfast and
it's so good
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
so to help remake we volunteered to do
some groundwork I don't know how much we
help but and so on this is before the
fire
um
oh my God
so this will burn down so they put up
this structure
while they rebuild it inside and is
aiming to be done in 2026. we were
supposed to go to this Castle when we
wasted Okinawa last time but we didn't
get the chance we could have seen it
what a massive project to rebuild that's
crazy
so we get special access to look inside
that's why we got this cool helmets on
looking cute Mercia
wow
oh they're working on the timber wow
[Music]
so this is the main hall so they had to
build wall uh roads even for
construction to come in and out some
places aren't remaining those are huge
foreign
[Music]
s are there's even more wood
we can see how they make them round by
just cutting all the corners
[Music]
it's Coral
better watch out
[Music]
now finally the sun this is the Okinawa
I want it we stopped for lunch by the
beach it's really pretty actually not
bad
[Music]
thank you
all right all my fish Lumbers out there
it's your time because we're going to
the Okinawa
aquarium there should be some crazy
fridges Japan always have amazing
aquariums
and this is supposed to be a really good
one they almost put the dates on the
Pokemon stuff I don't know why
what a view
you're not fooling anyone
[Music]
there's a puffer oh my God
where is it
[Music]
oh my God he's terrifying
he looked at me
the handsome Squidward of fish right
there they got the snakes
Marcia thinks that is cute
it's not cute it's horrible
still cute holy what Jesus
it's a monster that's a monster what
what is that get out of here
I never want to swim again
[Music]
thank you
apparently they discovered this fish
last year like they didn't even know
what this fish existed
and they named it at the bubble tea it's
like here
you thought you could hide all this time
but we found you
oh you look mean
check out these ones they're climbing
through it jump jump
it's okay
I missed that he left
we found him the big boy
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
shark
damn you're ugly
my name is goblina look it's Spider-Man
this place is so pretty
cool architecture that was amazing so
pretty what was your favorite fish
no
[Music]
thank you
good morning
today's the last day in Okinawa the sun
has left us again we're in the yachiman
street which is a pottery Street here
everything looks really pretty but I
think everything is closer a little
early they shouldn't be opening in a
couple minutes
[Music]
foreign
so these are called scissai they're
Okinawan Lions even in Tokyo I've seen
people have them by their entrances of
their houses usually there's a male and
then there's a female and the male has
the mouth open to scare away bad spirits
and the female has it closed to keep in
good spirits
foreign
[Music]
I settled for this little turtle
it was so cute and the lady that worked
there was so cute so I felt like I had
to we're heading back to the airport now
it's time to leave Okinawa
hello
[Music]